the most important thing a man can take
into combat it's a reason why you're in
this fight boy she marked my words
19 men attacked our country the 12 of
you will be the first ones to fight back
- knocking on door you know I love you
right I would be remiss if I did not say
to you even in success the odds of you
coming home you're a hundred percent sir
we're coming
[Music]
what is not follow you take me to the
Taliban I'll show you okay we take
horses be serious
all right who's written before anyone
can't kill Spring Break goes
[Music]
if she tells us it's okay to apply to us
be yours just an army of talk we've just
been handed the most important mission
of the free world
our boys are going to ride into battle
horseback
chances are we are not going to make it
out of this one
equipped now what happened back home you
got to make this decision
nothing I'd rather do oh man thought
you'd never ask
where the hell do those come from
baby's gums first
everything's good girl
[Music]
this is from the towers you carry that
with you
[Music]